JESS: Hi, everyone.
Hello.
Welcome to Authors at Google.
So, as you all know,
over the past decade,
Steve Jobs has changed
the way that we
think about giving
presentations by modeling
a new form of interaction
types of presentations.
Today, we are going to
hear from the man that
taught the world how
to be like Steve Jobs.
He has watched hundreds of
hours of footage of TED talks,
and today, he's doing
it again-- teaching
us all how to talk like TED.
Carmine Gallo.
CARMINE GALLO:All right.
Thanks, Jess.
Good afternoon.
Hello, everyone.
I feel like I have a lot
of microphones on me today.
There's multiple streams going
on, and that's why the mics.
This is such an honor for
me to be speaking at Google.
First of all, thank you
for changing the world.
That's astonishing and must
be an amazing experience
to work here.
That's what I want to
talk to you about today is
world changing ideas.
How many of you have good ideas?
How many of you think
you've got a good idea?
OK, most of you.
Your ideas are
your currency now.
Your ideas are the currency
of the 21st century.
In the information age,
the knowledge economy,
you're only as successful
as your ability
to communicate your
ideas persuasively.
How do you do that?
I believe that there are
three fundamental laws
of communications-- laws that I
learned after studying hundreds
and hundreds of TED talks and
also analyzing and interviewing
some of the most famous
TED presenters of our time.
Now, it's not just me who says
that communication skills are
so important.
Ben Horowitz is a very
well-known local venture
capitalist.
With Andreessen Horowitz, who's
behind Facebook and Twitter
and many other companies as
well, and obviously many of you
know him as a
substantial investor.
He was at South by Southwest
and he gave us this quote.
"Storytelling is the
most underrated skill
when it comes to
entrepreneurship."
he was speaking specifically
to entrepreneurs.
Storytelling-- the ability to
tell your story convincingly,
persuasively, in a way
that really engages me--
that's going to be your value.
That's going to help you
stand out in all of the noise
and to stand out and move your
brand forward and your careers
forward.
Ben Horowitz believes that.
I certainly believe that.
And this gentleman
believes that.
You may have seen him
before-- Warren Buffett,
the billionaire.
Listen to this
audio clip where he
is telling a group of
business students--
I believe this was
Columbia University--
he's talking to a group
of business students.
Listen to the value
that he places
on communication skills
and public speaking.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Right now I would
pay $100,000 for 10%
of the future earnings
of any of you.
So if anyone wants to see
me after this is over--
[LAUGHTER]
If that's true, if you're a
million-dollar asset right now,
right, if 10% of you
is worth $100,000?
You could improve-- many
of you, and I certainly
could have when I got
out, just in terms
of learning
communication skills.
It's not something
that is taught.
I actually went to a
Dale Carnegie course
later on in terms
of public speaking.
But if you improve your value
50% by having communication
skills, that's another $500,000
in terms of capital value.
See me after the class
and I'll pay you $150,000.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
CARMINE GALLO: Why
would he say that?
Because Daniel Pink, a noted
author, has recently observed,
"like it or not, we're
all in sales now."
That means that
you are constantly
selling yourself and selling
your ideas internally
and externally.
It's the 21st century.
We have new models of
communication, don't we?
We communicate in photos,
videos, 140-character tweets.
Well, I believe that a 21st
century model of communication
requires 21st century
techniques, which
is why I turned my lens
from Steve Jobs, who
was one individual-- and
in my opinion, the greatest
corporate storyteller
we've ever had--
and I turned my focus
onto TED, the TED talks.
TED, even though I'm
independent, I'm objective,
I'm not affiliated
with that conference,
I've worked with
many TED speakers.
I've interviewed TED speakers.
I've analyzed 150 hours
worth of TED content
and I've categorized it.
And I think I know why the
best TED talks go viral.
But more importantly for
all of us in the room
is what can we learn
from the world's greatest
presenters and speakers
that we can apply
to make our message, our
pitch, more persuasive, more
convincing?
Especially if you
only have-- let's
say you don't have 18 minutes.
You have five minutes
to convince your boss
to back your idea.
How do you get it across?
How do you persuade?
That's what we're going
to talk about today.
I believe that there are
three fundamental components
that all inspirational
communication has.
Any time there is a
conversation, a presentation,
a pitch that we
consider persuasive,
these are the three
components that they have.
They are emotional-- that
conversation is emotional.
You have to touch my heart
before you reach my head.
Those conversations are novel.
They teach me something new.
And finally, they're
also memorable.
It doesn't matter.
Your idea doesn't matter if I
can't remember what you said.
So we're going to talk
about each one one by one.
Let's talk about emotional.
How do we make ideas emotional?
First, passion.
Passion is everything.
You cannot inspire unless
you're inspired yourself.
It's also important
for your career.
Dr. Larry Smith gave a
very famous TEDx event.
He is a University of
Waterloo economics professor.
He's been studying passion and
entrepreneurship for decades.
And he says passion is
the thing, the thing that
will help you create the highest
expression of your talent.
I asked him after his TED
talk, I asked Dr. Smith,
how do you identify passion?
This all sounds good,
and I agree with it.
But how do you identify it?
What is it when we
say, that person
is passionate about something?
I want to follow my passion.
That sounds so cliche.
What exactly does that mean.
He pointed me to an excerpt
from his now-famous TED talk,
and here's what he says
about what passion means.
Probably the best
definition I've heard.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Passion is your greatest love.
Passion is the thing that will
help you create the highest
expression of your talent.
Passion, interest, it's
not the same thing.
Are you really going
to go to your sweetie
and say, marry me,
if you're interested?
Won't happen.
Won't happen, and
you will die alone.
What you want.
What you want is passion.
It is beyond interest.
You need 20 interests, and
then one of them, one of them
might grab you.
One of them may engage you
more than anything else,
and then you may have found
your greatest love in comparison
to all the other things
that interest you.
And that's what passion is.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
CARMINE GALLO: OK,
your greatest love.
By the way, he's really
passionate, isn't he?
He's worked up.
And I asked him, Dr. Smith,
you're going nuts on this.
What's happening?
He said, Carmine,
what you have seen
is 40 years of
pent-up frustration,
of telling people that
they need to follow
their passion in order
to create the highest
expression of their talent.
And he said, Carmine, wasted
talent is a waste I cannot
stand, which is why passion
is so important to him.
But I love that definition--
your greatest love.
How does that relate to us?
How does that relate to,
say, entrepreneurship?
I write for "Forbes," also
the books that I write.
I have this amazing opportunity
to interview and spend time
with some of the great
leaders of our time.
Let's talk about this idea
of your greatest love,
and what does that mean
to follow your passion?
Here's a photograph of
me and Richard Branson.
Richard Branson always
seems to be smiling.
I think when you've got five
billion reasons to smile,
you're always happy.
He's always happy.
But when I asked him,
what's your greatest love?
It's not-- it's not
getting people from point A
to point B on an airplane.
That's not his greatest love.
His greatest love is
disrupting the status quo.
It's elevating the
customer experience.
Some of you are familiar
with Zappos, I'm sure.
Tony Hsieh, who's sort
of elevated the customer
experience, speaking of that.
I've interviewed Tony Hsieh.
His greatest love
is not the shoes,
which is very interesting.
He sells shoes online,
but he wears old shoes
till they're worn out.
When I asked him, what's
your greatest love?
He never mentioned shoes.
He says it's
delivering happiness.
How can I deliver happiness to
my customers and my employees?
Which is why he's created
that great culture at Zappos,
a culture like many of you have
experienced here at Google.
The point is, he's
always thinking.
The most inspiring
communicators and entrepreneurs
don't really pitch
their product as much
as they pitch what
the product means
for the lives of
their customers.
Big difference.
Howard Schultz, the founder
of Starbucks-- actually,
they he's the founder.
No, he's the CEO of
Starbucks, and he's
going to explain in a video
clip I'm going to show.
But Howard Schultz,
when I interviewed him,
completely changed the way I
look at communication skills.
This was several years
ago for one of my books.
He spent two hours
with me and not
once did he talk about coffee.
I was the one who
brought up coffee.
That's because that's
not what he's selling.
He's selling a better
customer experience.
He is selling a workplace
that treats people
with dignity and respect.
He's selling community
and the romance of coffee,
but it's not about the coffee.
It's so much deeper than that.
He gave me a quote
that I'll never forget.
He said, Carmine, coffee is
the product that we make,
but it's not the
business we're in.
So you need to think about that.
That blew my mind.
I can't tell you what--
I mean, it completely
changed the way I
look at communication.
You've got to think
about not your product,
but what business you're in.
This week, Oprah Winfrey
created her first big product
partnership with Starbucks.
I think it's the Teavana brand.
Some of you may have that tea.
It was her first big
product partnership,
and she decided to go on a
partnership with Howard Schultz
because-- and I'm paraphrasing--
but she said because Starbucks
is so much more than a company.
It's so much more
than the coffee.
It means so much more.
That comes from him.
That comes from the
entrepreneur, the leader,
and the way he communicates
the vision behind his brand.
Watch this very short video
clip taken a few months ago
of Oprah Winfrey first
interviewing Howard Schultz.
Listen to the way he
talks about the brand.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-People think I'm the
founder of Starbucks,
but I'm was an
employee of Starbucks
when they had four stores.
I was sent to Italy to
do a trip for Starbucks.
I came back with this
feeling that the business
that Starbucks was in
was the wrong business.
-Because at the time that you
were employed by Starbucks,
they just sold coffee
beans, and they actually
did not sell a cup of coffee.
-That's correct.
And so what I
wanted to bring back
was the daily ritual and
the sense of community,
and the idea that we could build
this third place between home
and work in America.
-Can you take me back
to that little coffee
shop and the feeling
you had there?
-In Italy?
-Yes, absolutely,
when I was reading it,
it felt like an [INAUDIBLE].
-I was out of my mind.
Every--
-Had you gone in for coffee?
-Yeah, like anyone else.
But I walked in and saw
this symphony, the romance
and the theater of coffee.
And also, coffee can be a
center of conversation socially.
That is what spoke
to me, and that's
what I wanted to achieve.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
CARMINE GALLO: Coffee at
the center of conversation.
You see how it goes?
His communication
about his brand
goes so far beyond just
the physical product.
Passion, by the
way, is contagious.
I did a lot of research into
the science of persuasion
for my new TED book,
and I interviewed
neuroscientists and researchers.
What they're finding is that
passion is indeed contagious.
We already know
this intuitively,
but they are finding that if
you meet someone or listen
to someone who is genuinely
and authentically--
those are important words--
genuinely enthusiastic
about their product
and what it means
for the lives of
their customers,
that it will significantly
alter your perception
of that person and that product.
So you've got to
think about passion.
How do we transfer that passion?
How do we transfer what
we're excited about?
That's where we have to master
the art of storytelling.
All of the greatest presenters
in corporate America
today, and certainly on the
TED stage, are fantastic
storytellers.
Research is finding
some remarkable things.
A remarkable thing happens
to your brain on stories.
Princeton University
researchers have
found that if I
tell you a story,
the same areas of our
brains-- if they take an MRI
scan to look at brain blood
flow-- the same areas light up.
That means we are
literally in sync.
They call it
mind-to-mind coupling.
I just call it being in sync.
Stories are powerful.
Sheryl Sandberg,
Facebook COO, is
learning all about
the power of stories.
How many of you have
heard of the movement
that she started, Lean In?
Many of you, most of you now.
Lean In is a very
powerful movement
for young women
in the workplace.
I argue-- and if you'd like
to push back, please do.
Save your questions
for the Q&A. But I'm
arguing that you never
would have heard of Lean In,
you would not be
leaning in right now,
if it had not been for a viral
18-minute TEDx presentation
that Sheryl Sandberg gave that
led to a bestselling book that
eventually sparked the movement.
And here is why it went viral.
Sheryl Sandberg recently
admitted-- just a few months
ago, she talked
about the TED talk
she gave several years
ago that launched Lean In.
She was ready to give a
talk, in her words, that
was chock full of data
and no personal stories.
A friend of hers right
before the conference
pulled her aside
and said, Sheryl,
you look a little
out of sorts today.
What's going on?
And she said, it's
kind of been a bad day.
Right before I came
out to the conference,
my little girl was
tugging at my leg,
and she was crying and
screaming, mommy don't go.
But it's OK, I'll work it out.
I'll get it together.
And her friend said, why don't
you just tell that story?
Sheryl Sandberg was skeptical.
She said, in front of people?
You want me to tell that
story in a presentation?
And then she realized
she had to be vulnerable.
She realized that in order
to touch people emotionally--
isn't that what we're talking
about-- touching people
emotionally?
She had to break down that
wall and connect with them
on that personal
storytelling level.
Here is how Ms. Sandberg
started her now-famous TED talk.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-At the outset, I
want to be very clear
that this speech comes
with no judgments.
I don't have the right answer.
I don't even have it for myself.
I left San Francisco,
where I live, on Monday.
I was getting on the
plane for this conference,
and my daughter, who is
three, when I dropped her off
at preschool, did that whole
hugging the leg, crying,
mommy-don't-get-on-the-plane
thing.
This is hard.
I feel guilty sometimes.
I know no women,
whether they're at home
or whether they're in
the workforce, that
don't feel that sometimes.
I'm not saying that
staying in the workforce
is the right thing for everyone.
My talk today is about
what the messages are
if you want to stay
in the workforce.
And I think there are three.
One, sit at the table, two--
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
CARMINE GALLO: The story.
It's the story that went viral.
She applied the same technique
to her book, "Lean In."
Again, the first
chapter was all data.
No personal stories.
Her husband-- true story, she
just said this a few weeks ago.
Her husband read the
first chapter and said,
this is like eating
your Wheaties.
Because we know it's good for
you, but it's kind of boring.
The book itself is
now full of stories
if you read the first chapter.
18 minutes leads
to a best seller
leads to a movement for
millions of young women.
An 18-minute presentation has
the power to start a movement.
I studied 500 TED talks.
Categorize the content,
and here's what happens.
Pretty fascinating.
Aristotle, for we
communication geeks,
is the father of persuasion.
He said that
persuasion occurs when
you have three
components-- pathos, which
is what we're talking about
now-- emotion, storytelling.
Logos is data, statistics.
Ethos is establishing
credibility for who you are.
65% of the majority of the best
TED talks-- 65% are stories.
25% data, only 10% ethos.
Sheryl Sandberg's
talk was 72% stories.
Bryan Stevenson, for example,
tells a lot of stories.
Bryan Stevenson is a
civil rights attorney.
He knows how to talk to people.
He successfully wins cases
before the US Supreme Court,
which, if you haven't guessed,
is a pretty tough audience.
He knows how to persuade.
When he gave a TED
talk last year,
he received the longest
standing ovation at TED.
I talked to him afterwards.
He told three stories
from his life.
He supports the
stories with data,
but the data come
after the stories.
So his template is stories data,
stories data, stories data.
He includes the data, but
he supports his argument
with stories.
His argument is, as a
civil rights attorney,
that young men and women in
underprivileged and underserved
communities are incarcerated at
a much higher rate than others.
That's his theme.
I want to show you a
clip from this TED talk
because again, he received the
longest standing ovation at TED
because it was deeply emotional.
Here, he tells a story
about his grandmother.
I've got to set it
up for just a second.
He said that his
grandmother pulled him aside
when he was 11 years
old and said Bryan,
I want you promise me never
to drink alcohol in your life.
And Bryan said, well,
OK, I'm only 11.
So, sure.
Sure, I'll go along with it.
Here is how he
picks up the story.
His theme, by the way, was
there's power in identity.
Watch and listen for how the
story reinforces the theme.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I grew up in the country,
in the rural South,
and had a brother a year older
than me and a sister a year
younger.
I was about 14 or 15
when one day my brother
came home and had
this six-pack of beer.
I don't know where he got it.
And he grabbed me and my sister
and we went out in the woods
and we were kind of just
out there doing stuff
we crazily did, and he
had a sip of his beer
and he gave some to my
sister and she had some,
and they offered it to me.
I said, no no no, it's OK.
Y'all go ahead.
I'm not going to have any beer.
And my brother was like, come
on, we're doing this today.
You always do what we do.
I had some, your sister
had some, have some beer.
I said no, I don't
feel right about it.
Y'all go ahead.
And then my brother
started staring at me.
He said, what's wrong with you?
Have some beer.
And then looked at me
real hard and said,
oh, I hope you're
not still hung up
on that conversation
Mama had with you.
I said, what are
you talking about?
He says, oh, Mama tells all
grandkids that they're special.
I was devastated.
And I'm going to admit
something to you,
I'm going to tell you something
that I probably shouldn't-- I
know this might be
broadcast broadly.
But I'm 52 years
old, and I'm going
to admit to you that I've
never had a drop of alcohol.
I don't say that because
I think that's virtuous.
I say that because there
is power in identity.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
CARMINE GALLO: You
see the template.
Story ties back to
the central theme.
There is power in identity.
Now look, I don't
have all the answers.
I'm constantly
learning something
about communication
and persuasion.
That's why I talk to
people who, frankly,
are more persuasive than I am.
If you win Supreme Court cases,
you're pretty persuasive.
You know how to talk.
So maybe Bryan Stevenson has
some pretty good answers.
Maybe we should listen to him.
Storytelling is powerful.
How many of you enjoy consuming
organic fruits and vegetables?
Most of you.
I see downstairs they had
a nice organic section
of the restaurant.
You have this woman to thank.
Her name is Myra Goodman.
Myra Goodman, several decades
ago with her husband Drew,
started a two-acre
raspberry farm
and grew it into what is now
Earthbound Farm, the largest
grower of organic
produce in the world.
If it wasn't for
her, you probably
would not be having the
abundance of organic
that you do because she
really pioneered the movement.
She called me in
October and she was
getting ready for a TEDx talk.
For those of you who don't
know, TEDx are the smaller,
independently
organized TED events.
She called me in
October and she was
getting ready to talk to this--
it was a food-related event.
She knew that I had just
finished a book on TED.
I've known her
for several years.
She said, what advice
can you give me?
I said, please
start with stories.
You've got some great stories.
You've got good data.
You've got awesome
data, but we're
going to wrap that
data in stories.
For example, I said,
Myra, I love that story
that I remember long
ago when you told me
that you started literally
selling raspberries at a farm
stand in Carmel, California,
and now you go into every Costco
and they've got the
entire section of organic.
Here's how she
started her TEDx talk.
I think it was-- actually,
it was just a few weeks ago
in March.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I have been a passionate
advocate of organic farming
for 30 years.
I can still remember
the exact moment
when I knew I didn't want any
chemicals to grow our food.
It was just two days
after my husband Drew
and I moved onto our original
two and 1/2 acre raspberry farm
in Carmel Valley,
and I was standing
between two rows of raspberries
near a little orchard of fig
trees surrounded by the
gorgeous green mountains,
and the miracle of what
was happening around me
was stunning.
I was 3,000 miles away from my
11th floor on East 36th Street
here in Manhattan, but I felt
like I had finally come home.
I just knew in my heart that
we shouldn't try and conquer
this beautiful earth
with chemicals.
Drew felt the same way, so
right from the beginning,
we made the commitment to
learn to farm organically.
Back when we started
Earthbound Farms,
Drew and I were two
faces of small organic.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
CARMINE GALLO: I
just realized-- I
don't know why it's happening--
but I can see it in real time
here, and it looks like there's
a slight delay when you see it
on the projector.
What did you notice, by the way?
I know we're going to
have some Q&A in a minute,
but what did you notice
about the slides?
What did you notice about the
slides that she presented?
AUDIENCE: Personal.
CARMINE GALLO: Personal.
Personal, visual, pictures.
When we tell stories,
we don't want
to clutter the slides with a
lot of words, charts, and text,
because it's about the story.
The visuals
complement the story.
Make sure that we--
we can talk about this
when we have the Q&A
if you have questions.
Save your questions.
So emotional, touched my
heart, passion, storytelling.
Also, ideas that spread,
which is the TED motto,
"Ideas That Spread,"
teach me something new.
Teach me something that
I've never heard before.
Something new,
unexpected, or surprising.
There's science behind this.
Dr. A.K. Pradeep, who is a
neuroscientist in Berkeley,
said that our brains are
trained to look for something
brilliant and new,
something that stands out,
something that looks delicious.
When the brain detects something
new, surprising, shocking,
unexpected, it
literally releases
dopamine, which acts as
a mental save button.
I interviewed Robert Ballard.
Robert Ballard
discovered a little ship
you may have heard
of, Titanic, in 1985.
I actually asked him, I
asked the silliest question.
What makes you more
nervous, actually public
speaking or exploring
the undersea world?
He said, Carmine, almost
dying 2 and 1/2 miles
beneath the surface of the
Atlantic is a lot scarier
any public speaking.
He has no stage fright anymore.
He said, your mission
in any presentation
is to inform,
educate, and inspire.
Think about that.
That's a powerful line.
You can only inspire
when you give people
a new way of looking at the
world in which they live.
Researchers call that new way
an emotionally charged event.
It simply means that when
you perceive something
that is fresh, unexpected,
surprising, and new,
it actually creates
that dopamine
hit that I told you about.
It's called, in the
academic research,
an emotionally charged event.
OK, so what does that
mean in a presentation?
How many of you have seen or
remember the now-famous TED
talk by Mr. Bill Gates?
What do you remember
the most from
that particular presentation?
AUDIENCE: When he
released the mosquitoes.
CARMINE GALLO: When he
OK.
Wait a minute, don't you
remember the third slide?
You don't remember the--OK.
His slides were
professionally designed.
They were really nice slides.
You don't remember the slides.
You remember the
emotionally charged event.
So here, for some of
you who didn't see it,
Bill Gates is talking about
reducing childhood deaths
in third world countries,
deaths caused by malaria.
Here's how he picked it up.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-For example, there's more
money put into baldness drugs
than are put into malaria.
Now, baldness is
a terrible thing.
And rich men are
afflicted, and so that's
why that priority has been set.
But malaria-- a million
deaths are caused by malaria
greatly understate its impact.
Over 200 million people at any
one time are suffering from it.
It means you can't get the
economies in these areas going
because it just holds
things back so much.
Malaria's, of course,
transmitted by mosquitoes.
I brought some here so
you could experience this.
We'll let those go around
the auditorium a little bit.
There's no reason
only poor people
should have the experience.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
Those mosquitoes
are not infected.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
CARMINE GALLO: OK, thank you.
Thanks for putting me at ease.
I know as a fact that Bill
Gates is significantly
working at improving his
communication skills because he
has to transfer very
complex information
and he needs to make it
simple, engaging, memorable.
This is one example.
It's an extreme example.
You're not going to
release mosquitoes
at your next Google meeting.
I get that.
But it's an example
of creating what's
called that emotionally
charged event.
The reason why
you remember it is
because you did not expect
Bill Gates to release
a jar of mosquitoes
in a presentation.
It's different.
How many of you may
remember watching last year
Amanda Palmer-- a performance
artist, a musician--
give a TED talk?
Did some of you see?
OK, this one actually went
viral for a few weeks.
It became very, very popular.
Amanda Palmer is a musician.
I'm not even sure where the
music would be categorized,
something like indie
punk cabaret rock.
Some of you might be familiar
with those categories.
This particular presentation
that she gave last year
was viewed more than
5 million times.
She practiced a lot.
We can talk about practice
maybe in the Q&A and rehearsal.
She practiced more
than 100 times
on this particular presentation.
But here's what people
remember the most--
the emotionally
charged event from
this particular presentation.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-So I didn't always make
my living from music.
For five years after graduating
from an upstanding liberal arts
university, this was my day job.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
CARMINE GALLO: OK, so now she's
talking about being a living
statue, and she's going to
talk about her experience
and then bring it back into
what she learned about the music
business.
That's what people
remember most.
Why?
It's completely unexpected.
She's using props.
She's using visuals.
She's telling stories.
It is very unlike
the way you would
expect most
presentations to start.
The reason why, if you watch
a presentation or a movie
or any kind of
visual event, you're
going to remember one part.
That one jaw-dropping moment.
That's what I mean by novelty.
You need to teach
me something new,
but also shake out
the cobwebs, shake out
the way the brain is modeled
to perceive information
and give them
something entirely new.
Steve Jobs, the reason why I
first wrote about Steve Jobs,
he was brilliant at this.
He didn't these extreme things.
You never saw Steve Jobs stand
on a milk crate or release
mosquitoes.
Those were extreme.
But what did he do?
Oh, but there is one more thing.
When he first did that, that
was completely surprising,
completely unexpected.
Steve Jobs was brilliant at
that and incorporating something
new and novel into every
one of his keynotes.
Finally, the brain
has to remember it.
It doesn't matter.
Your idea, your
presentation, the beautiful
slides-- it's not
going to matter
if I don't remember the content.
Let me give you some
very specific techniques
on making your pitch
more memorable.
All TED talks, as
you probably know,
are limited to 18 minutes.
The 18 minute rule.
It doesn't matter whether your
name is Bill Gates, Sheryl
Sandberg, or this week, Sting.
Sting talked, last
year was Bono.
Doesn't matter who you are.
You're only limited
to 18 minutes.
That's not a bad time limit.
In fact, the TED
organizers found
that 18 minutes is long enough
to have a serious discussion
and short enough to
keep people's attention.
There's science behind this
that you as communicators
need to know.
It's called cognitive back log.
Researchers at Texas Christian
University are working on this.
It simply means that
if I ask you retain
more information, the more
information I pile on,
like weights,
pretty soon, you're
going to drop the whole thing.
Cognitive back log.
In fact, they're
finding-- depending
on the research-- anywhere from
about 10 minutes to 18 minutes,
people start losing attention.
They actually will physically
start looking at their watch,
look at their
phones, and thinking
about what they're
going to do next.
From 10 to 18 minutes.
So during that time, you
need to reengage them.
I'm going to speak
for-- I'm going
to break the 18 minute rule.
I'm going to speak for
more than 18 minutes.
We're going to break that up.
We're going to have some Q&A
so it's not just me speaking.
I'm trying to add video
clips so there's two voices.
Those are different
ways of reengaging.
But if I were to just stand
here with no visual display
of content, no information,
no second speaker
and I just talked
to you, by now,
you'd be ready to
tear your hair out,
no matter how engaging a
speaker you think you are.
The brain naturally tunes out
after about 10 to 18 minutes.
That's a very powerful concept.
It's very important
to understand
when you're giving a
pitch or a presentation.
A lot of great things
can happen in 18 minutes.
John Kennedy inspired
a nation to look
to the stars in 15 minutes.
Steve Jobs gave one of
the greatest commencement
addresses of our
time at Stanford.
That was 15 minutes.
Martin Luther King, he
took a little extra time
to outline his vision
for racial equality.
That took about 17 minutes.
Sheryl Sandberg started a
movement is about 16 minutes.
Al Gore's "An
Inconvenient Truth"
was originally a TED talk.
Launched the whole
global warming thing.
A lot of initiatives,
movements can
start in as little
as 18 minutes.
Think about keeping
your content concise.
And then think about this other
technique that is so powerful.
It works almost every time.
I'm not going to
guarantee you anything,
but this is close--
the rule of three.
The rule of three means that in
short term or working memory,
you're only capable of caring
about three big ideas, three
chunks of information.
If I ask you to
remember a phone number,
you divide up into
chunks of three and four.
Threes is a very
powerful number.
It pervades every
aspect of our society.
From slogans like "Just Do
It," or Obama's "Yes We Can."
Company names-- SAP, IBM, CNN.
And certainly literature-- "The
Three Musketeers," "The Three
Little Pigs," "The Three Bears."
The rule of three.
Authors know this
very, very well.
Writers know this very well.
Great presenters
know it very well.
Bryan Stevenson
told three stories.
He did not tell 12 or two.
Told three.
It's an important number.
The brain needs more than
one, but after you give it
about five, six,
or seven points,
it starts to forget everything.
Three is a really good number.
Tell your boss there's
three reasons why
you should back my idea.
There's three reasons.
There's three new
features of this product
that I think our consumers
are going to like.
When I was analyzing all the
TED talks, take a look at this.
These are just some examples
of the rule of three
from the best TED talks.
Three reasons why
videos go viral.
These, by the way,
are not necessarily
the titles-- some of them are,
but most of them are not--
but it's the theme of
the actual presentation.
Three reasons why
videos go viral.
Three ways design
makes you happy.
Three ways the brain
creates meaning.
Three clues to
understanding your brain.
A lot of brain stuff.
AUDIENCE: That was four things.
CARMINE GALLO: That was four.
There was a bullet of four.
But there's more.
Three ways brands lose control.
Three ways crooks steal
your digital data.
Three myths about big organic.
And of course, three things I
learned when my plane crashed.
The rule of three.
Very, very powerful.
I do a lot of what's
called media training,
so I work with executives
before they go on
to import media interviews.
Three always works.
I hate to sound
too manipulative,
but this is how the brain works.
If you give people three things
that they need to keep in mind,
they'll write them down.
They want to know,
what's the third?
Or what's the second?
Did I miss the second one?
People cannot ignore lists.
Three is a good list.
And finally, to make it
memorable-- especially
when we're delivering it doesn't
matter what software you use,
either Google software or
traditional PowerPoint,
or I use Apple Keynote or
Prezzie, think visually.
Think visually.
This is called
picture superiority.
Picture superiority means
that if I deliver content
to you verbally, you'll remember
about 10% of the content.
If I add a picture or an
image, retention soars to 65%.
The average PowerPoint
has 40 words.
Several years ago, when I
started analyzing Steve Jobs'
presentations--
and again, I think
we'll all acknowledge he was
the original great corporate
storyteller-- I never found one
slide, never, with 40 words.
In fact, on average, it took
him 10 slides to reach 40 words.
It was all pictures,
images that spoke so much
more than any text could.
When you're talking about a new
computer like the MacBook Air
and you want to talk about how
thin it is, no number of words
could describe it
like that photograph.
So thin it fits inside
an office envelope.
When you watch some of the great
TED presentations-- and Bono
did a beautiful one that
you can go onto TED.com
to watch-- that was
created in Prezzie.
Beautifully done.
Some data, mostly
images and pictures
that supported the data.
Steve Jobs, his PowerPoints
are very unlike anything
that you used to see
from him and Microsoft.
They're very visual, this whole
idea of picture superiority.
Whenever you see
major executives now
give presentations-- maybe
not internally, but certainly
to external customers
and at external events--
they're are all
using this style.
Whether it's Google-- I've seen
a number of executives using
this style-- Marissa Mayer
is now using it at Yahoo.
She's building
beautiful presentations
if you saw her at CES.
Actually, she was doing it here.
She was still doing it here.
Zuckerberg over at Facebook,
and Apple, certainly, they
continue to use this style.
It's more of a visual style.
You need to think visually.
This is an actual slide from
Bill Gates' slide, where
he was talking about
global warming.
His formula-- he said it's a
really simple formula-- as CO2
goes up, the
temperature increases,
which leads to some
really bad things.
OK, he's trying to
simplify complexities.
When you simplify complexities,
you need a simple slide.
So that's an actual slide from
a Bill Gates presentation.
You can do this--
I remember working
for LinkedIn before
they went IPO.
They started using some
picture superiority
to explain what they did,
especially in the marketing
department.
This is a before slide.
This is an after slide.
So you see the difference.
Here, it's a lot of numbers.
The most important
numbers get lost.
But if that's all
I want you to know
is how many members we have
and how many members we're
collecting every month, you
can tell this is an old slide.
Only 70 million.
This was before
they event went IPO.
But again, it's let's
think about how are we
going to display
information visually.
Those are the three
components that all inspiring
presentations need to have.
They all need to be emotional.
Passion, storytelling.
They all need to be novel.
Teach me something new,
unexpected, fresh, surprising.
And of course, memorable.
There are a number of
techniques that you
can use to make sure
that people recall
the information that
you've given them.
Above all, keep this in
mind-- that you do all
have the capacity
to move people.
You all have the capacity
to educate, to electrify,
to inform, to inspire.
You have ideas.
All of you have big,
bold, transcendent ideas
that need to be heard.
Please communicate those ideas
as persuasively as possible
because we need to
hear those ideas
and we need to be able
to act on your ideas.
Thank you very much for
inviting me this afternoon.
Thanks, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
For those of you who
have a few minutes,
we are going to have the
"Talk Like TED" book.
I'd love to sign them for you.
But if you have any questions,
I'd love to take them.
Yes, Jess.
AUDIENCE: We've heard a lot
about the way that [INAUDIBLE]
structure of the presentation.
I'm curious if you have any
thoughts on how [INAUDIBLE]
CARMINE GALLO: So
how TED as a concept
has affected
presentations and society.
I wrote a column for "Forbes,"
and I said, like it or not,
your next presentation is being
compared to TED because you
can't argue with the
empirical evidence.
The empirical evidence shows
that we have two million TED
videos stream every single day.
They are being seen
in 150 countries.
They're being translated
into 90 languages.
This style-- fresh,
engaging, visual, emotional
is catching on.
I've traveled to Europe
and I've traveled to Asia.
I'll never forget
being in Japan.
I've had several people in
Japan come up to me and say,
we love the whole American
style of presenting.
And I said, what's
the American style?
One person said,
you know, like TED.
People see TED.
True story.
I had a rabbi come up to me.
This didn't happen too long ago.
A rabbi came up to me,
and he said, Carmine,
I need to improve my sermons.
I said, well, why?
He said, people in
my congregations
have told me I've got
to step up my game.
One person said,
we see TED talks.
Whether you're a spiritual
leader, whether you're
a business
professional, there is
this new and fresh dynamic way
of presenting that people don't
know what they're looking
for, but they know it
when they see it.
I think that's what TED means.
Yes, Toni, right?
Toni.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering
if you can just
talk about the application
of these principles
to communication.
[INAUDIBLE]
CARMINE GALLO: Perfectly.
So how do you apply this
to written communications?
The rule of three.
Rule of three works beautifully.
You have to have a headline.
That's the theme of
your presentation.
All TED talks, they
all have themes
that fall into 140
characters or less.
You can actually
tweet out the headline
from every theme
of every TED talk.
You could tweet them out.
They're that short.
And then, so give me a headline.
What's the one thing you want
me to know in this email,
and then break it up.
Give me some white space, just
like a nicely designed slide
should have some content
and some white space.
If you fill it up with content,
then it's very hard for the eye
to analyze.
What's the one thing you want me
to know in this email, the one
action you want me to take,
and three supporting points.
That's actually not a bad
way of structuring an email.
Whether it's a TED
presentation or it's an email,
you can use of the
same techniques.
AUDIENCE: I was
thinking more about what
you do in your
articles, for example.
CARMINE GALLO: In my article.
Articles are structured very
much like a presentation.
We put most of our
thoughts into the headline.
What is the one thing
I want you to know?
The headline would be the title
of your talk, for example.
That would be number one.
Then I'm going to think
about what story am I
going to start
with, what data am
I going to use to
support my argument,
and the examples
I'm going to use.
Very much structured
like a good presentation.
I'm a former journalist.
I worked for CNN and CBS and a
number of other media outlets.
We're storytellers.
We think in stories.
I think that's what a great
presentation does, too,
especially from the
examples you saw today.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: When I
was at IBM, we used
to joke about
making presentations
to senior executives only
three points because they
couldn't absorb anything else.
[INAUDIBLE] here got
thrown out of the room.
What can I do for
people who actually
don't care about emotion?
They want the real numbers.
They are going to
push back really hard.
[INAUDIBLE]
CARMINE GALLO: Yeah, push back.
Because I am so confident,
I am absolutely,
110% confident in
these techniques.
I'll tell you why.
I have worked with
nuclear scientists
at Lawrence Livermore Lab.
I live out in
Livermore, Pleasanton.
I worked with nuclear
scientists at Sandia in Mexico.
Nothing-- I know what you
do is complex-- nothing
is more complicated than nuclear
weapons and nuclear science.
They're using these techniques
pretty effectively now.
When we say three, it
doesn't necessarily
mean I'm only going to
deliver three points.
That's a great question.
It doesn't mean I'm just
going to deliver three points.
But I'm going to try
to break up the content
so it's not just a flood of
information coming at you.
I'm going to break
it up into chunks.
Maybe there's a component
within my presentation
that focuses on
the three features,
and then within those
I have subpoints.
I gave you a lot more
than three techniques,
a lot more than
three techniques.
But I tried to make it simple
in terms of the categories.
There's three categories that
the techniques fall into.
It's pretty powerful.
But you also bring up
another good point.
Do not walk into your boss and
give a TED-like presentation.
You can take elements
from this, but it's
somewhat of a contrived
scenario, right, this whole 18
minute thing?
You don't want to
distract people
by doing something so
different and unexpected
that it actually
becomes a distraction.
But I would urge you to start
using some of these principles
to make for a more engaging
conversation and more
engaging presentations.
Look, I'm not going
to mention the name,
and I won't mention
the company because he
might recognize himself.
An executive middle
level manager
called me from a global
technology company
that all of you would know.
Called me last year.
He said, Carmine, over
the last two years,
I have improved my
presentation skills.
He showed me a deck very unlike
the decks that are typical
and standard at this
particular tech company.
It's very old school PowerPoint.
His are more like this.
He said now, he's been
considered an evangelist
and he is being blown all over
the world to give presentations
to prospects and to new clients
because even area managers know
they can't give a presentation
as good as this guy can.
So he's actually been
labeled evangelist.
I said, what does that
mean to your career?
He said, well, in a
company of 80,000,
it gets me a lot closer to
being a country manager.
And a country
manager in my company
is the equivalent of a million
dollars with salary and bonus.
So presentation skills in two
years went from old school
to radically different, has
actually elevated his stature
within this company.
Again, it does come back down to
public speaking, communication,
persuasion.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Whenever anybody
has to stand and up
talk about standing up and
[INAUDIBLE] but I really
enjoyed the presentation.
CARMINE GALLO: You
enjoyed it, good.
Thank.
AUDIENCE: I notice it's about
the craft in your presentation.
Obviously, you
tried to illustrate
the points you're talking about.
CARMINE GALLO: You're suggesting
I didn't give you everything.
AUDIENCE: Well, I was going
to ask a simple thing.
Content aside, what are the
three most important things
about presentation.
CARMINE GALLO:
I'll give you one.
Practice.
That's what I didn't talk about.
You only hear this
when you talk to people
who are great presenters.
You wouldn't get it just
from watching a TED talk.
Some of the best TED
talks, the ones that
have been seen 20
million times were
practice and
rehearsed 200 times.
That Amanda Palmer
one was practiced,
she practiced it 100 times.
Remember I showed you
that Myra Goodman?
She practiced every day
for about three months.
Every day for three months.
Dr. Jill Bolte Taylor, which
she is a Harvard researcher,
she has the second
most viewed TED
talk-- about 15 million views--
she practiced 200 times.
Steve Jobs practiced,
and I know this
as a fact, practiced
relentlessly.
He knew every font,
every slide, every demo.
Drove his engineers crazy, but
he made sure that he practiced.
That's why he made
it look effortless.
When you see a presentation
that looks effortless,
it's because a lot of
work went behind it.
Let's do this, folks.
I will be around
for a few minutes.
I'm going to be around
Is there one more question?
AUDIENCE: Just wanted to know
if you had any insight as to how
one gets elected
to give a TED talk.
CARMINE GALLO: How does someone
get elected to give a TED talk?
It's very difficult to be
on the national TED stage.
This year, it was
held in Vancouver.
It's only held once a year.
That's the big TED stage.
That's where you see Sting
and Bill Gates and the others.
Apparently, Sting gave
a sensational TED talk
in Vancouver.
It hasn't been uploaded yet,
so I can't wait to see it.
Unless you're curing malaria
or your name is Bill Gates,
probably aren't
going to be invited.
It's very, very difficult.
But there are the lower,
the smaller TEDx talks,
which are regional,
community based.
Some are much
better than others.
Some are more
prestigious than others.
You can go directly to
the websites of those TEDx
organizers, and they're always
looking for great speakers
locally.
And guess what?
The video still goes
to the TED page.
It's still in the same network.
I'm going to hang around.
I'm going to sign books.
I'd love to talk to you,
I'd love to meet as many
of you as possible and continue
to answer your questions.
Jess, thanks for inviting me.
Thanks, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]